- When like the show first
comes on and it says Netlix.
(imitates Netlix sound effect)
(electronic sounds)
(jazz music)
- Probably Gaten, because
I feel like he'd just watch
a bunch of Ken Burns documentaries
and just cloud up my feed,
make look just sad 'cause
he was watching sad stuff.
You know what I mean,
and Gaten just pushes,
"did you see that doc?"
I'm just like "yeah dude, it's really sad,
"I don't really wanna,
"I don't wanna hear about
it right now." (laughs)
He was a huge, Gaten's
just a real history buff
and a lot of history is super sad.
And so sometimes he
talks, he's not a downer,
he's not as much of a downer
as I'm making him out to be,
he's like a sweet puppy dog,
but sometimes he'll say
something where I'm like
"man I don't wanna hear that today."
(laughs) It's sad.
So yeah, probably Gaten,
I would not trust that man
with any password in my life.
I would trust him with like a bomb
that he had to diffuse or something,
'cause he's trustworthy like that.
But not for a Netlix account.
(beeps)
There was that show Sex
Ed, which I really liked
which is on Netlix.
But I'm trying to think of something
that we all raved about.
I remember I just saw Mid
90s, Jonah Hill's Mid 90s
and I was raving about it on
set a lot and talking about it.
Oh yeah, we talked about Star Wars a lot,
that was the season.
I remember at least five
different conversations
about the new Star Wars movies.
(beeps)
I don't know, I liked them.
I don't have any problems with them.
I like episode three a lot. (laughs)
I like the lava fight at the end
where Anakin burns to death. (laughs)
But it's fun, I don't
know, I liked those movies.
(beeps)
- Oh man, well, I had a VHS player
up until I was 10, or like nine or 10
and so,
I watched, some of the first
movies I ever watched was
we had a box set of
Revenge of the Sith and
A New Hope, so I watched
it really early on.
(beeps)
Yeah, yeah, I dunno.
I guess VHS was introduced earlier.
I think a lot of my friends
grew up with more DVD players
but I grew up with VHS.
And then moved slowly to DVD
and then Blu-ray when the PS3 came out.
(beeps)
Yeah, definitely.
I think was again, like
it was on accident,
but it makes so much sense.
Certain things identified with me so much
just 'cause all the Duffers' influences
and all the Stranger Things influences
are all movies that I
grew up watching, so,
it definitely came full circle for sure.
(beeps)
Ooh, Barry.
I just watched Barry, finished it.
Like I said before, I
watched all of Sex Ed,
which I really liked, thought
it was super fun on Netflix.
Yeah, Barry, I was super behind on Barry.
I had only seen the first episode
then I just binge watched the first season
and season two now.
But that was probably the
last thing I did, yeah.
(beeps)
I got a text from a
bunch of friends saying
"there's Bob Dylan vibes" so,
yeah they're very big compliments.
I mean from music, for
sure, but style never,
or look has never been Bob Dylan,
even now that's what comes out.
I hope I get to see that dude,
'cause he's getting older now.
So, hope I get to see him
before he kicks the bucket,
one day.
(beeps)
When I was younger I didn't
really have like, a set style.
I was kind of into
skater clothes and stuff,
so I'd just wear straight
skater stuff and baggy clothes
and then I started doing
more stuff like this,
so now I wear more like, I don't know,
70s rock stuff and,
it's like a 70s rock with like,
skate culture vibe,
I've no idea.
I just wear whatever I think is
cool and comfortable I guess.
And like makes you feel more unique
because it's not as
much of a thing anymore,
but I think that look
is coming back for sure.
There's a reason why Reebok
Classics are huge now again,
and all the vintage stuff you see,
that's why Stranger Things
has a collab with Nike now,
with the Cortez's and stuff.
(beeps)
Whatever, I'll still throw on a t-shirt
and gross sweatpants and walk around.
Crocs. (laughs)
(beeps)
I mean I would love to see myself
on a set for the first time.
'Cause that was the moment that
everything clicked in my head and,
it was probably the most fun I'd ever had.
I'd love to go back and see that happen.
I remember I was just so excited,
and I was probably, I couldn't shut up,
could not stop talking about
everything and cameras,
I was just so overstimulated.
So if I were to ever go back
I'd just tell myself to shut up.
And just watch and just learn.
(beeps)
Dude,
Spiderverse was amazing,
the last Spiderman movie.
I saw that in theaters
twice, just 'cause I,
it was something so unique.
The animation was so unique
and I hadn't seen something
like that in so long.
And it's old now, but it came
out like 10, 11 years ago
but all the old Laika stuff,
I haven't seen any of their new stuff
but Coraline and ParaNorman
and all that stuff is amazing.
And occasionally I'll watch some anime.
I'm not like huge into anime or anything.
Fullmetal Alchemist:
Brotherhood is really good
and Gurren Lagann is great.
And Akira, Akira's one of my
favorite films of all time.
I don't know if that classifies as anime,
but you know, I watched it.
(beeps)
Doo-doom?
Like the game Doom?
(laughter in background)
Doo-doom!